we are back to the present with Saturn
in full fight mode the return of Luffy
and even a shocking character arrival to
Egghead during the chapter that changes
everything not to mention a frightened
for the first time Saturn getting his
well-deserved just deserts so make sure
to stay tuned for this insane chapter
because many have been waiting for this
one while the flashbacks were going on
in previous chapters so make sure to
stay tuned for the Glorious payoff now
channel pring within and smash that like
button if you enjoy seeing one piece
reviews like this on the channel and
want to keep them coming make this the
video you join the knock if you haven't
already by subscribing by doing so
you're also helping us inch closer
towards our huge goal of 2 million
subscribers here on YouTube and now
without further Ado let's jump into It
spoilers and all so last chapter was
finishing up the heartbreaking Kuma
flashback we got to relive fan favorite
moments from a different perspective
like of course the nothing happened
moment but we also got to see new scenes
like Vega Punk crying while erasing
Kuma's Free Will and memory and Kuma
revealing that his last wish is for Vega
Punk to tell Bonnie that Kuma wishes her
a very happy 10th birthday Bonnie saw
this all when she touched Kuma's memory
bubble and then we saw her in the last
panel tears running down her face it
seemed like Kuma had forgotten about her
because the CP agent kept destroying her
letters but now she knows just how much
Kuma loved her and sacrificed for her
it's arguably the best backstory in the
series it takes us perfectly into this
chapter called I'm sorry Dad or I'm
sorry Father it's clear after the
flashback not only who Bonnie really is
now but also why she blames Saturn for
what happened after all it was scientist
Saturn's idea to do this tokuma and as
we'll see he did even more heinous
things that will be revealed later on
this chapter it's way more his fault
than even Bonnie knows so far Saturn
after this chapter May well be the most
hatable character in the series as we'll
get into so this chapter starts where
the last one left off and once again we
are getting very dark indeed within one
piece so this chapter starts where the
last one left off Bonnie was crying
after seeing Kuma's memories and here we
get Vega Punk running into her after
that moment so this is like the not too
distant pass but still technically like
a little flashback but it's still during
the egad arc Vega Punk asks her have you
seen it all meaning Kuma's memories and
Bonnie says yes Vega Punk apologizes for
breaking the promise he made to Kuma
while Bonnie turns into her true little
girl form and hugs Vega Punk she cries
say she's sorry to him she obviously
misjudged the situation misjudged him
because she didn't have all the facts
but now knowing what we know and that
Vega Punk tried his best to help Kuma
she thankfully understands that he's not
the villain here we also find out that
Kuma gave Vega Punk a gift for him to
give Bonnie he says it's a gift for her
10th birthday we see Bonnie truly light
up a rare occurrence these days and it
is because she's happy that she got
something from Dad she's beaming she
looks at the necklace and says it's
beautiful it's a SA fire and it looks
just like the sun kind of weird that
Kuma would pick a sapphire with all the
suffering caused by the sapphire scales
but there will probably be a good reason
for it like it's definitely intentional
MEAP Punk says that Kuma said it was
meant to be a protective charm now is it
possible it's tied to the current Kuma
being able to track her down somehow as
a pacifista so he can still protect her
we'll see then they start talking about
straw hat and how he evolved so much the
past two years so much so that no one
could have imagined it Bonnie knows that
he is the child of a very good friend of
dads meaning dragon and Vega Punk
responds yes I was surprised to see you
two ended up coming here together fate
is such a strange thing and when you
think about it it really is cool that
just like their parents it seems like
these two are going to end up being
really good allies and like I've been
saying hopefully so much so that Bonnie
joins the crew drop a hashtag Bonnie for
straw hat in the chat if you agree Vega
Punk explains that a lot has happened
since she went into the room with the
memories and now he is actually being
saved by straw hat he says he'll tell
her everything but for now she has to
calm down so they can join up with them
Bonnie then once more thinks to herself
Vega Punk's words when he said he had no
choice she thinks to herself that it is
not the fault of a scientist doing his
job the ones who are truly to blame are
these guys and at this point we jump to
the present with a struggling Bonnie
being held by Saturn so yes we are
finally back in the present with all
that back the rearview mirror adding way
more weight to the scene right now
Saturn continues to be hatable no
surprise and decides to tell this little
girl after making her suffer so much
that her father Kuma is dead Sanji
really wants the help of course you know
Sanji but he still can't move his body
Saturn has some crazy power holding even
hella strong Fighters back on the bright
side Luffy seems to be recovering he's
still withered but better enough to ask
for some food he asks for meat and Atlas
wants to oblige but she can't move move
either meanwhile the Marines have
captured sentomaru kizaru is still on
the ground thinking to himself sentomaru
Bonnie remember this dude ate pizza with
them dance with them and spend countless
other moments with them in the past he
mentored sentomaru and knows that Bonnie
is just a little girl I've been talking
about kizaru's internal conflict for a
long time now and seeing Elder Saturn
trying to kill Bonnie in this chapter
May finally wake up kizaru and make him
Rebel for once let me know what you
think Kizer will do next in the comments
even if you think it'll be just him
laying down for the rest of the Ark then
we see people reacting to the news of
this Siege and how it's even bigger than
the one at Ohara they say a barricade
set up by an emperor would only mean
death and then we get the hype inclusion
of the revolutionaries namely Dragon
Ivanov again who are obviously very
relevant to Kuma's backstory and by
extension to this whole Arc Dragon says
if Kuma started going after the Instinct
fragment where do you think he would go
Eva and Ivanov says if it was me I'd
certainly go to marija and then it's
concluded so Kuma was wrong after all
now what exactly is the Instinct
fragment I'm not sure but like I said
could that Sapphire protective necklace
in Bonnie's control be calling out
tokuma now even as he's supposed to have
lost his memories and Free Will I wonder
but we have to wait and see either way
good to see in the present that we are
still getting Dragon revolutionary
moments and it gives me more reason to
hope that my wish will come true and
they will come to help at Egghead I
think it's about time and it would all
tie in really well with Duma but back to
Bonnie she says even if it kills me I
will kill you Saturn she uses her broken
distorted future power and Saturn
notices it's similar to na she hits him
but nothing really happens she asks why
am I becoming weak again and Saturn says
you are his daughter after all of course
you would know about that name but you
don't know what that is exactly he
thinks the white form of NAC from Straw
Hat doesn't seem to have connected to
her internally yet end quote he then
says it is truly disappointing meanwhile
Luffy is seen eating a bunch of food now
clearly getting better Saturn is angry
at seeing this and asks which one of you
gave him food immobilize his hands
immediately use a sea Stone handcuff
submarines had to deal with him but
noticeably kizaru does not move we just
see dots where his thoughts should be
maybe he still can't move but even so
even if he could he still seems unsure
of what to do next then Bonnie realizes
that like the others she is affected by
the presence of s
and for her she says she can manipulate
her age near him then we get a huge
bombshell Saturn says that the one who
gave her this skill was him Saturn
himself they conducted an experiment on
a certain baby where they gave them the
skills of a devil fruit without making
them eat it directly we administered it
with an extract although it was a
success it is indeed an unnecessary
fruit the user is able to transform
however they want regarding the
foreseeable future however its abilities
are severely decreased when one's
knowledge of the the future differs from
reality in other words Bonnie wants to
believe in Na and she swore she would
search for na when her dad became a
cyborg slave so that they could free her
dad again and give him freedom however
at the first evidence that Kuma was dead
she was weakened as this is being said
though we see beat up Kuma remember he
was beat up a fair bit by sakazuki when
he attacked marijua and then disappeared
again he lost part of his face and a
foot it seemed but now we see him
heading fast somewhere and I think we
all know where that is so it seems
Bonnie's doubt about what's possible in
the future can limit her powers which
explains why a young kid with a lot of
Hope and belief would be so powerful
using this ability but if she sees Kuma
come to the rescue that may have the
opposite effect on her powers instead of
getting weaker they could get stronger
so we'll have to wait and see for that
Saturn continues that her father meaning
Kuma who believed in worthless Legends
told him that he wants to save people
just like na and and then as I mentioned
earlier Saturn reveals that he's more to
blame than even Bonnie knew and even
more so than we could even imagine he
says it was also me who experimented
with drugs in your mother the one who
would later become the eighth Lady of
the holy land now that sounds crazy too
there's so much crazy stuff going on in
this chapter the eighth Lady of the holy
land that suggests that Jenny was
potentially married to a very powerful
Celestial Dragon indeed also the term
lady tends to go with the term Knight in
my mind so it could be possible that one
of the God's Knights married her the one
called the eighth Gods Knight we did see
a silhouette of nine of them after all
when we first heard about them but who
knows I have even heard theories that
Saturn could be the one that married
Jenny which would just make him the
biggest villain in anime probably and of
course Bonnie's dad as well making all
of his current actions all the worse I
look forward to seeing how the official
VI translation translates this part
though since it will give us much more
to go off of and it is a very big line
so we need as much as we can get but
back to Saturn the villain from hell and
he says the side effects didn't stop
showing up when he experimented on Jenny
the blue marks were still appearing it
was a failure so those who realize that
blue sapphire is a gemstone associated
with Saturn and that thus the character
Saturn may have been the cause of the
sapphire scales seem to be proven right
here it seems that the disease in jinny
was caused by Saturn's experiments what
a monster this dude is you just can't
say that enough about him he's like a
truly evil mad scientist unlike Vega
Punk he then says it didn't go very well
so even her child inherited that
condition so yes Saturn is the cause of
Jenny and Bonnie Sapphire scales and the
reason Kuma had to sacrifice his life to
save them in the first place man I can't
wait for Saturn to get his just desserts
in this Arc please don't make us wait OD
up so then Bonnie says crying it was all
your fault she sort of said that before
but now it is even more obvious Vega
Punk is furious not having known this
and says you were toying with Kuma's
family by using an illness such as
Sapphire scales this was the reason why
Kuma gave his life away and then Saturn
says that people should see it from his
perspective he says are you saying that
I should understand the feelings of an
insect that is impossible so he's
positioning himself here as a God and
perhaps his being Immortal and not aging
has something to do with it as well but
either way he views other humans as
insects feeling fully Justified and
treating them in whatever way he pleases
since they are so far beneath him got to
hand it to Oda it's good that we hate
Saturn so much because it means that Oda
is doing a great job with his villain
and when he gets defeated it will be all
the sweeter then we get the huge reveal
yes Kuma was heading over to Egghead
itself the Marines see him and notice
it's the original they Proclaim he is
advancing to the center of the island
and the command triip is not working
they say we can't stop him now it would
be hilarious if sakazuki ended up
accidentally destroying the command ship
with his attacks and that's why now they
can't control him but it's all
speculation at this point and even if
the command ship is no longer working
what is guiding him here if he
supposedly lost his Free Will and
memories again is it that protective
charm AKA necklace Andor is he not fully
gone and for his impon sake I hope he's
still in there somewhere at least part
of him even Saturn is surprised saying
what is this stupid mess there's no way
Kuma could come here Bonnie thinks it's
impossible she is too scared and Vega
too the one who may have secretly
implemented something in Kuma seems to
be surprised as well suggesting he
didn't actually do anything perhaps
science just isn't capable of fully
erasing all the free will inside a
person that does seem to be something
that would go along well with the one
piece message either way dad is coming
to the rescue and going to prove to his
daughter that she can believe in him and
in a brighter future which as I
mentioned in turn may increase her
abilities we see him running and people
shooting at him and he just keeps
running and even sweating Bonnie thinks
to herself hey Dad it looks like your
heart is breaking down we see him taking
shot after shot as they shoot until
there's no more bullets Kuma keeps
getting up and Bonnie is crying thinking
at this point it would be better if she
just died she apologized to her dad
saying the title of the chapter I'm
sorry Father everyone is Frozen like
Sanji but the one man that is supposed
to have no free will keeps moving
forward to save his daughter Mega Punk
says shut up brat your yelling won't
make any differ difference and just as
it looks like Bonnie is finished and she
apologizes that it looks like the life
Kuma fought so hard for is about to be
lost Kuma appears picking up Bonnie and
shielding her from Saturn's finishing
blow Bonnie is finally face to face with
Kuma again after so long as she's crying
and screaming father and of course you
have the nose tears thrown in as Oda
loves to do that's how you know it's a
big serious cry then Kuma takes Saturn's
spider-like spiky leg with one hand and
prepares an insane punch he's about to
hit Saturn who looks worried even
sweating the narrator says Kuma is
unleashing his anger he's unleashing all
of that stored up suffering and I could
not be happier that all of Saturn's
horrible actions now seem to be coming
back to haunt him in the form of this
Frankenstein esque monster that he
himself created this was definitely one
of the best chapters in a while and
that's saying a lot because all of these
chapters were actually really good and
my hype for the next chapter with this
Cliffhanger is off the chart Arts that's
for sure but if you enjoyed this one and
the new information about devil fruits
then you won't want to miss our recent
video about every type of devil fruit
explained link on screen right now like
And subscribe to help us reach 2 million
nakama here on YouTube and I'll see you
in the next one